We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P you
can call anytime of day.
Here is a really interesting question about
the phrase.
I don't know as in, I don't know the answer
to that.
Oh, Hey David.
Uh, if this gets through then, uh, cool.
Uh, so I just wanted to see what your thoughts
were about this sort of concept.
Um, I feel as though many political figures
as well as just people in general are sort
of scared as they think.
Like, I don't know, or I need to look more
into that.
And that sort of thing, uh, in the landscape
of like seemingly endless political facts.
Personally, I would love the sort of authenticity,
uh, but I think many people are scared of
like a Gary Johnson, Aleppo kind of situation.
Um, so anyway, let me know what your thoughts
were about that.
Yeah, I've been talking about this for awhile.
I would much rather hear from people, I don't
know enough about that yet to have an informed
opinion and uh, I, I simply, I'm not in a
position to take a strong, uh, position one
way or the other on that right now.
The problem is that while if you don't know
something you, you should, you should be comfortable
saying that you are under informed about that.
You also might be in a position where you
should know about that thing.
Right?
So in other words, when Herman Cain was running
in 2008 or 2012, I think it was, and on so
many issues, he said, I don't know, but I'm
going to put in a team and they're going to
figure it all out.
At a certain point you've got to know something
about important issues.
If you are trying to say, I should be elected
to do something or I should be the CEO or
whatever the case may be, there is no problem
in principle with recognizing where you lack
information or you lack knowledge and simply
saying that you are going to get more informed
as a societal principle.
That is a good thing.
That doesn't mean that being uninformed in
every situation is innocent or not something
that we should be concerned about.
So I think that's a difference.
When Gary Johnson said, what's Aleppo?
Um, the issue was not necessarily that he
didn't have a fully fledged out policy on
Aleppo and troop movements and foreign policy
issues around that.
That's one thing.
He seemed to have no idea what Aleppo is.
The fact that Aleppo is a sear is a city.
Right?
So that that was the problem.
And while as a society, we should encourage
recognizing we have information shortfalls,
understanding where we lack a new and nuanced
enough understanding of an issue to take a
position.
There are times where if you don't know, you
probably just shouldn't be in the position
you're arguing you should be in, and it's
important to keep those two things separate.
We've got a fantastic bonus show for you today.
We will talk about Bernie Madoff asking for
compassionate release.
We will talk about
a paid dad believed in addition to mom leave
in Finland and very bad news for Macy's, the
retail channel, all of those stories and more
on today's [inaudible], the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].